Nice to meet you guys. Um I'm Ash. Uh
this is Andrew. We both work in uh as
engineers in our applied AI uh team here
at Anthropic. Um and the kind of topic
for this session was uh inspired by a
blog post we put out uh just a couple
weeks ago actually um about how to think
about building uh agents that can
actually run for really long extended
periods of time. You know you're talking
five six hour plus kind of runs. Uh, I
think we've all seen these kind of
demos, you know, of like companies being
like, hey, we've like oneshotted a
browser, for example, but not
necessarily sharing like some of the
details into what goes into the harness.
And that's what we kind of want to talk
about today. So, the first half, um, my
amazing colleague Andrew will talk about
a little bit about basically how we've
got here, some of the primitive that
we've shipped in called code, um, and,
you know, where we are today. Um, and
then I'll hop back on stage to talk a
little bit about um, some of the more
experimental stuff that we're playing
with with harnesses um, as well as, you
know, a few examples of of what we've
seen. But over to you.
>> Sounds good. Thank you, Ash. And yeah,
thanks everyone for joining uh, first
session of the AI engineer conference.
So glad you're spending it with us. Uh,
my name is Andrew. I'm on the applied AI
team based out of London working as a
solution architect with a lot of our
digital native and industries customers.
So, um, yeah, I'm going to give a little
bit of a history tour, uh, trip down
memory lane, but really with the focus
on all the things that we've shipped
that lead to agents being able to run,
uh, for multiple hours or even days at a
time. Um, and then I'll hand over to Ash
to do more of the the state-of-the-art,
right? Okay. So, um, little quote from
or on Twitter from Boris, the creator of
Claude Code. This was on the one-year
anniversary of Claude Code. uh basically
saying a year ago cloud was struggling
just to write bash commands and escaping
strings um and it could run for you know
maybe 20 minutes at a time and then
we're now at the point where almost all
of cloud code is being written by cloud
code and it can run effectively for days
at a time. Uh so sort of a a big a big
swing over just the course of a year and
I'll walk through that history uh a
little bit now. But just to maybe I'll
zoom in here. Um just to sort of frame
the problem up like why why is it that
it's really difficult for these agents
to run for extended periods of time. Um
I think broadly there's three big
buckets. Uh some are more intuitive than
others. So firstly context. I think we
all understand context windows very much
finite. So you start a new session,
there's like amnesia. The agent has to
start from scratch. So you need some
sort of memory component. Um, also as
you're working through a context window,
there's this notion of context rot. So
there's less coherence as you're you're
getting deeper into that session. Uh,
also you might get to the point where uh
the model actually exhibits what's
called context anxiety. So it gets kind
of nervous as it reaches the end of its
context window and it just quickly
hurries up to finish what it's doing.
Um, this kind of leads into planning. So
uh in general models are not that great
at planning just out of the box. Uh they
might try and do everything in just one
shot or for example they might build
half a feature and then stop or they
might just run out of context altogether
and sort of leave a half-finished app
built. Um but then maybe less
intuitively um models are really bad at
judging their own output. So I know we
all know that models can be sickopantic
and sort of tell you what you want to
hear but this applies as well to to
coding tasks. So it might look at a
feature and see that it's sort of half
halfbaked or a little bit implemented
and say yeah okay uh that looks done and
then it'll move on to the next thing or
it might build a feature like a button
but actually the back end you know
doesn't exist for it. There's sort of no
nothing behind that but it looks like
the feature is done. So um I know Ash
will talk quite extensively of some of
the new techniques we have to to help
with this um specifically so models can
become better at judging their own
output.
So there's there's two ways really we
can we can fix these things. Uh the
first one is obviously the model. So u
baking it all into the model weights
themselves. And I'm sure you've all seen
this this meter chart. It's basically
how long can an agent run for with a
minimal scaffold uh where it's
completing 50% of the tasks. And you'll
see from opus 3.7 it's around 1 hour and
up to opus 4.6 one year later it's at 12
hours. So an entire day. Um and we've of
course you know managed to get that
running much longer. Other people have
as well but this is just a sort of a
very minimal scaffold.
The second thing that you can do is of
course make changes to the harness
itself. So this is the scaffolding um
around the model and we have the agent
SDK which ships with all the primitives
that we've been building over time. So
there's the core agent loop itself where
you have clawed model that's determining
what to do, what tools to run. Uh maybe
it's pulling in some tools from MCP
servers. Uh it might delegate some tasks
to a sub agent. It's bringing in all the
context from things like claw.md or the
skills that are loaded or slashcomands.
There's a whole permission system. And
th this this will change over time as
well as the models get better and
improve. But these are sort of the the
core primitives that we're working with.
And then of course you use this
framework to to build your own harness
for whatever it is you're trying to do
such as some of the things that Ash will
show uh later on when we get into more
longunning agents. Uh I think what's
also interesting is just looking back at
the last year of releases is that when
we've released a model, we've always
also released a lot of harness changes
alongside the models. So really these
things are like co co-evolving together.
So we'll just look back um I suppose
firstly just prehistory um beyond you
know one year ago. I think we all
remember that that period where claude
had the artifact section of claude.ai
and and sonnet 3.5 was the first model
that really showed promise when it came
to coding and it could now verify that
it could look at what it had built and
sort of iterate from there and that was
quite an aha moment sort of pre-clawed
code. Uh but then also we shipped
computer use so it could start clicking
around taking screenshots um testing its
own code as well as MCP spec uh which
enabled it to sort of use tools.
So then getting into cloud code. Uh this
is February 2025. So this is about just
over a year ago. Um Sonnet 3.7 was
released and sort of state-of-the-art on
Swebench and Claude Code was released in
research preview. And I think an an
interesting quote that I pulled from
this release actually is that the goal
of Claude code was to better understand
how developers use claude for coding to
inform future model improvements. So
essentially when we released claude code
the whole idea was for it to be somewhat
experimental to inform how we actually
improve the base model itself. And
you'll see this trend that over time the
models become better uh the harness
certain aspects of it might become less
necessary or it will evolve.
Um just just in terms of uh these slides
as well in the bottom left corner these
are some of the things that are sort of
the focus of these releases whether it's
uh context or planning uh or
verification and then some some stats
but I'm not going to sort of read
everything. Um so yeah next this was
around May time of last year Opus 4 and
Sonnet 4 were released and just in
general um these tools got much better
at sort of managing their own context
and getting to task completion uh
without reward hacking or anything like
that and then uh cloud code became GA as
well and we released the cloud code SDK
so sort of the the harness powering
claude code
um little interlude here from the
timeline I think everybody now knows
about this Ralph Wigum technique
You might not know that it was actually
last July that this was that this came
out uh when when Jeffrey Huntley
initially released the paper because it
really sort of gained a lot of traction
around say December or so of last year
uh when for example people started
playing around with it themselves.
Claude also released our own uh Ralph
loop within the the Claude code uh
harness itself. But essentially it's
it's quite sort of a simple technique
that you're just taking a prompt and
you're feeding it into cloud code CLI
for example and then you're just running
that on a loop until uh all the tasks
are complete. It's a little bit deeper
than that. I I think people tend to
simplify it. There's actually a few
phases where it first, you know, would
have some kind of planning where it
breaks down that prompt into a few
different features and then it would
pick sort of one task from that and
start a new session and then work with a
fresh context window. So a lot of those
concepts were were applied in the real
flute but I think um why it caught so
much attention is because it sort of
seems really simplistic and he put it uh
deterministically bad in an
undeterministic world. So the idea being
that it's better to fail predictably
than it is to succeed unpredictably. Um
when we actually created our own plug-in
for this in cloud code you'll see well I
don't know if people can recognize what
what the major difference is. There's
some people say, you know, that's not a
real rail loop. Um the idea is that this
is just running within a single cloud
code session. So it's not creating a
fresh context window. It's just relying
on compaction to happen over time. So
you know, maybe it's not considered sort
of a real RA loop, but you'd set the max
iterations. You'd set a a safe word, and
then essentially a stop hook would
intercept when claude would typically
stop, and if it's not finished, it would
just sort of continue until it hits one
of those exit criteria.
Okay, so on to uh sonnet 4.5. This was
when the model just generally started
getting better again at handling its own
context. So this is when became more
context aware tracking how many tokens
had been consumed. So as it got towards
the end of the context window, it sort
of understand that and it could manage
its own context. Um cloud code 2.0 also
shipped. This is where we introduced
checkpoints. So actually keeping track
of of the code over time being able to
rewind to previous parts of the session.
And then we released we just sort of
renamed the cloud code SDK to the agent
SDK and that's because we realized it's
much more general purpose than actually
just for coding. So you'll see we're
talking about coding a lot right now but
I think what's very interesting is
applying these longunning harnesses to
um other domains as well.
Uh at this point we could run for about
30 hours or so uh with Claude uh Sonet
4.5. But then completing the family with
Haiku 4.5 and Opus 4.5. This is where it
got really interesting because all of a
sudden running many sub aents became
really economical and opus 4.5 became
really good at planning. So we could
start doing things like using opus 4.5
for planning. Um and then using sonnet
4.5 is the workhorse for really
executing all of that code. Um and then
there's there's a big couple months as
well because this is when we release
skills which again very good at uh
making use effective use of the context
with this notion of progressive
disclosure. So just the front matter of
the skill is loaded in instead of sort
of all of your tool descriptions you
know which can consume quite a lot of
the context window up front. Um, and
then sort of the entire rest of the body
of the skill is loaded in if it's
instantiated followed by say some
references um to even even code that
could run more deterministically. And
then more context improvements, things
like programmatic tool calling. So
instead of running a bunch of tools,
pulling all of that into context and
then trying to process it, actually just
writing code on the fly and being able
to sort of run a series of tool calls
and then just get the final result back.
And again, this is all just to improve
the the usage of of the context window.
Okay, so a lot going on on this slide,
but at this point, um, this is around
November time. We released our first
blog post on longunning agents and and
how you go about building these. So a
lot of the concepts I've already
described um should make this fairly
easy to understand actually where say a
human would write something like you
know write me a browser or create a
slack clone or a Salesforce clone just
something like really really vague and
uh the first thing that would happen um
in this harness that we built is there's
an initializer agent that would take
that simple prompt and it would break it
down into a series of of persistent
artifacts. The first being a feature
list of say x number of features feature
list.json because we actually found the
models might overwrite markdown files
whereas they're they're less likely to
just overwrite JSON files which is kind
of interesting. Um it would also write a
progress file um of course sort of start
the git repo uh build in a nit script
and then just have a flag for you know
whether the features are complete or not
if they sort of pass all the tests. Um
from there it would go into this harness
loop where uh there's multiple different
steps here. So the first one is you know
again in a fresh context window just
getting the bearings. What's the present
working directory? Um what's the the
progress file say? Okay. And then u
doing a smoke test. So running the init
script so it didn't have to figure out
how to do that every time get the server
up and running etc. Uh and then picking
one feature only one feature that that
hasn't passed all the tests. um
implementing that feature, doing some
actual tests, much so verification loop
much like a human would do using
Puppeteer in this case. Um and then if
if everything passes, actually writing
the git commit and um changing the the
state of of this particular feature to
passes and then if there are any
features that are unfinished, just
continuing that loop in a fresh context
window. So, we're starting to layer in a
lot of these concepts here. Fresh
context windows, these sort of
persistent artifacts, verification
loops, um really good planning up front.
You'll see like this this is sort of the
first iteration of of these longunning
harnesses here.
Okay. So, uh continue with the history
tour. So, then Opus 4.6, Sonnet 4.6. Um
these models are really great because
Sonnet 4.6 6 was basically offering that
opus level intelligence more at the the
set price and it became again like very
much a workhorse for a lot of cloud
code. Um and Opus 4.6 just became really
good at planning. We we called it very
much an agentic model. So Opus 4.6 was
great at at deciding like which tools to
use and just being able to run for much
longer. uh if you recall that meter
chart you'll see that this was a jump
from about four hours up to 12 hours
with sort of that very simple harness.
So this model is like very very agentic.
And then along with that um with some of
the research we had done we released
agent teams which the idea being in
cloud code this sort of more general
purpose way for you to say scaffold out
your own set set of of custom agents.
And the innovation with agent teams is
that instead of everything reporting
back into the main agent um the actual
sub agents could could communicate with
each other. So they sort of had their
own way to coordinate and then report
back to the main agent only when it was
required. Um we also introduced
serverside compaction which basically
meaning that these models can now just
run indefinitely and compaction could
just sort of you know happen on the
server side. And then um this 1 million
context G. So now we have like one big
context window. You see like the models
are getting better. Maybe you can just
run a lot you know within a single
context window even instead of
necessarily needing new sessions all the
time. You see how things start shifting
over time. So that's sort of the uh the
whole overview. You can see all of the
different uh releases that I shared here
on this table and you can see how it's
changed from say sonnet 3.7 at 1 hour uh
to 12 hours with opus 4.6 six and then
we have our own anecdotes as well um
where task would take say you know like
20 minutes when it was Opus 3.5 and now
we're building say fullyfledged apps
that don't have to run for you know 30
hours they can run typically we're
seeing like say 3 to five hours you can
build like a really really fully
featured application that that runs out
of the box
so what's really interesting is is the
harness doesn't just disappear as the
models get better. It's really evolving
as the models change over time. And it's
really fascinating to sort of find the
the gaps in the model and then fill that
in with the harness and then you train
the model on um the using that aspect of
the harness. Then maybe at some point
you actually remove that entirely and
sort of this iterative uh loop just
keeps happening over time with with more
and more of these sort of co-releases
that we have. So, um, yeah, hopefully
that was interesting little trip, uh,
back through the clawed evolution and
how it applies to the long running
agents. And so, I'll I'll hand over to
to Ash to continue with where we are
today, uh, in terms of the
state-of-the-art.
All right. Um,
quick question. Any of you guys have any
agents running at the moment in the
background doing work while you're here?
Just one, two, three. Okay,
probably should be more of you. Um, uh,
hopefully by the end of this you'll have
some ideas to like take away and
actually like put into practice. Um,
so yeah, that's that's a history. Um,
and I quite like that quote that uh
Andrew talked about where the frontier
doesn't really shrink, it just uh moves.
And so what I want to talk about a
little bit is some very simple uh kind
of harness patterns that we've been
playing around with internally that we
use to to build these like very fancy
oneshot demo apps. Um but also you know
we're experimenting with this stuff in
post- training um in in RL how do we
make our models and and just the general
behaviors more adept at uh autonomous
work.
So,
if you've ever tried to get um an agent
to try and review its own PR, um you'll
kind of understand uh where this is
going. So,
this general uh idea is shamelessly kind
of stolen from from GAN's uh genative uh
kind of adversarial networks. So you
have this uh generator kind of model and
then you have some sort of discriminator
um and uh you have some sort of
adversarial pressure between them. You
know the generator builds the evaluator
grades um and the whole idea here is
we're splitting up you know the context
windows uh system prompts uh uh the jobs
entirely. Right? The evaluator here
isn't just reading diffs, but it's
actually using playright um to open live
pages, click around, try things out um
and then it eventually hands back
whatever critique gets decided back to
the actual generator and you you know
you kind of continue that loop. Contrast
that with what most people today are
doing, which is kind of using one claw
code session, telling it to check its
own work um uh and kind of loop that
way. So the obvious question for me at
least is, you know, if the evaluator is
also just an LLM, um why doesn't it just
rubber stamp it too?
And so the key idea that we're kind of
exploiting here is um yes, the evaluator
is still uh a large language model and
yes, it's still going to be biased
towards uh liking large language model
style outputs. Um, but tuning a
standalone critic um to be harsh is
actually very tractable. But tuning a
builder to be somewhat self-critical um
is is not. I think a really good analogy
for this, right, is is same as humans.
Um it's very easy for uh me to you know
critique
a lovely piece of artwork or you know a
fine meal. Um much harder for me to
actually go ahead and like you know
paint that uh or or cook that meal
myself. So what we're doing here is
exploiting the gap between the ability
of an LLM to be kind of a critic uh
versus a generator.
So the next thing I kind of want to talk
about is like how do you actually think
about designing uh these critics? It's
very similar to the process of creating
good eval but in the context of full
stack apps there are a lot of fuzzy kind
of areas which go into what makes
something good. It's not just does it
work but does it look good? Does it feel
good? um is there an element of taste um
uh in these kind of products as well?
So this is where we've been doing a lot
of experimental work um especially when
trying to you know imbue Claude with
design taste and post training um but
also um you know create these kind of
front-end design skills that we kind of
put out there and just generally improve
the the front-end design uh ability of
of our models. So, the way we think
about this is
most people say you can't grade taste,
but you know, we think you can if you
have a a strong enough opinion on it,
and you just kind of write it down. And
so, the way we do this at least is with
kind of creating a rubric with four
criteria, uh, design, originality,
craft, and functionality. Um, we
actually weight this towards uh design
and originality. Um, we've kind of
shifted the waitings between these four
things uh depending on which model's in
play. But at the moment, you know, Opus
46 is pretty good at at at functionality
already. So, the problem that we're
trying to overcome is how do we prevent
things like, you know, purple gradients,
general kind of AI slop type aesthetics
in general. And we kind of just go ahead
and calibrate this with a few short
examples um on reference sites. So the
evaluator's kind of taste converges on
our own. Um, and
let me show you an example I guess of
what this actually looks like uh kind of
in in practice. So
this is just an example um of a model uh
going through this similar kind of loop.
Generator uh evaluator launches
playright navigates screenshots scores
on those kind of four criteria writes
critique and then hands back to
generator. So all of these examples are
just HTML and CSS only um that I've gone
through for maybe four hours, 5 to 15
rounds. Um I think the interesting thing
here um which is quite unique and
something which you wouldn't necessarily
get um if you're just using a single
kind of agent loop is that the thing
pivots, right? So imagine the generator
gets stuck on one of the fraud criteria.
Let's say it's like really struggling
and constantly scoring low on
originality.
um you know uh this kind of GAN style
harness which we're using will just
throw the whole thing out and try again
from scratch. Um whereas uh in a single
pass generation or a Ralph loop um it
gets it keeps trying to patch the same
thing. Uh and this kind of ability to
kind of course correct over very long uh
kind of time horizons is something which
is quite unique uh to kind of breaking
down the different roles uh that go into
to building something.
So that was just an insight into I guess
how we think about the front end
component. Um but how to go from kind of
like just nice pages to fully working
apps. We added uh one more role
um a planner. And so again sounds very
simple. Um it's ultimately just taking
kind of a oneline prompt um and then
breaking it down into uh a very
deliberately highle uh kind of spec.
So
what it does is actually just spec the
granular um uh sorry it kind of specs
uh the general workflow into a series of
sprints. Um what it doesn't do and and
what most harnesses do today is
necessarily try and plan the granular
technical details of of the product. The
reason being is you know one it's very
likely to still make an error but when
it does make an error it's going to
cascade um through every single one of
these sprints. uh and kind of magnify
errors over a multi multi-our time
horizon. If you kind of squint uh at
this um this is kind of just you know a
very simple kind of like PM IC and and
QA kind of or structure right like we
didn't invent this um we just kind of
gave each role its own kind of context
window. Um
and the bit which is kind of interesting
I think to talk about is the glue
between the generator and the evaluator
in this kind of setup.
So before the generator actually goes
ahead and write a single line um we have
the two agents basically negotiate what
done actually means and so let's say the
generator proposes um I'm going to build
X feature um and you should verify it by
testing Y. um the evaluator might push
back and be like actually uh the scope
is too big and those tests that you
propose are a bit too weak uh and you've
missed XYZ edge case and you basically
have this back and forth uh via files on
disk. one writes a markdown. Um the
other reads it um and you iterate until
both agree and then once you kind of
reach that kind of condition um
then you actually start building. Uh and
then the evaluator kind of grades
against the contract um that those two
agents have decided between themselves,
not the original spec which the planner
has kind of oneshotted at the beginning.
And why this matters um as it kind of
bridges this kind of idea of kind of
user stories uh i.e. the spec um and
kind of converts it into slightly more
tangible testable kind of assertions
some sort of contract uh without the
planner having to oversp specify kind of
upfront
and I think this is kind of the key
innovation that the Ralph loop never
really had. It had a kind of fixed plan
MD style uh kind of thing, but nobody uh
on the other side is necessarily arguing
with kind of the main loop. And again,
it comes back to like having these
separate context windows and adversarial
pressure. So, let me show you an example
of uh a very simple prompt that we had
um uh in a solo kind of group versus uh
the harness that we just discussed. So,
the prompt was basically
build a retro game maker. Um, and and
that was it. And I'm not, you know,
going to going to try and convince you
that this is like necessarily the most
cost-effective or most efficient way to
try and build an app. Um, as you can
see, one, it takes uh at the moment an
extremely long amount of time. Um, two,
it's very expensive. But also uh as
we'll see in a second, a lot of the
stuff actually starts working only uh
with this harness um when it didn't in a
kind of a solo loop. So this is uh what
it kind of looked like the opening
screen at least when we didn't have the
harness. Um pretty simplistic, a little
bit boring. Um but it still looks nice,
right? Um if this were the whole app, uh
you'd chip it, but it's kind of the
bait, I guess, uh if you will. Um, this
was kind of the uh sprite editor, if you
will. Again, it still looks fine. Um,
the canvas is there, the pallet, the
frame timeline, live preview. Maybe it's
a little bit cramped. Um, uh, and the
color picker is just black swatches, but
it it kind of works. Um, clearly the
agent like actually did understand what
it was trying to do. Um and then the one
thing that you actually has to do um uh
which is play mode entities rendered um
score, health, all the other things
which go into an actual game. Pressing
an arrow key does nothing. Pressing a
space key did nothing. Um the agent
really didn't have any idea um how to
test itself uh uh what it actually meant
to play a game and and actually succeed.
Um,
and yeah, this is kind of the same
prompt, same model. Um, and this is kind
of the the breaking point. It kind of
looks done on the surface, but when you
try and actually push it to its limits,
it just uh it just kind of failed. And
then if we ran the same prompt with the
same model, this is kind of what it
looked like uh when we ran the harness.
So, this was about yeah, 200 bucks, six
hours. Um, first up, it decided to name
itself um RetroForge.
um it decided to like create a new
project dialogue um have a very nice
canvas. Um none of that was in our
prompt. So this was all the planner um
deciding like okay uh here's what the
product decisions should look like and
then you know the two other agents
deciding right how am I going to test
this?
Um if we look at the sprite editor um we
have kind of a full 54 color palette. um
the kind of 8 bit preset from the
project dialogue flowing through. Um you
see the sprite at actual game scale. Um
it's a lot more complete uh as a product
in general. Um we had a whole new kind
of AI level assistant. This is where
it's kind of started to get recursive.
The planner had decided like right we
should have some AI features um which is
just a v vague line in the spec. And the
harness turned that into a full AI level
assistant inside the app that it it was
building. So, you know, someone could
come in and say, "Hey, create a castle
uh with sprites guide guarding it."
Let's say um
this is something which the solo run
would never even attempted to look at.
Um without the planet, that phrase just
becomes never even comes becomes like a
work item to look at.
Then finally I guess um uh the actual
results kind of applied. So
play mode um you know you have this
whole debug HUD in the top left um which
you can clearly tell is to make life
easier for for for the evaluator for
example. Those numbers are live. The
physics loop is actually running. Um
arrow keys work. The player moves. Um
Collider's Castle Wars. um because the
evaluator actually launched the game,
tried to play it, knew necessarily like
what what features needed to be tested
to make this game kind of real and
successful. Um and the difference
between this output and you know the
previous output is entirely just
scaffolding. It's a very simple loop
ultimately, but the results are quite
startlingly different at least.
And so in case you're curious, the kind
of things which the evaluator did catch
um are pretty basic kind of stuff. It's
things like um you know fast API route
ordering um passes every unit test but
might actually break in prodal
um catching things like the delete key
um having some kind of boolean logic
bug. Um again these are things which
were only caught because that evaluator
is actually using the app. Um it's
things which might get through CI in a
RA loop. Um um but
this isn't you know that level of
specificity isn't something which
happened by accident.
And so
this is the kind of level of detail
which these models are kind of going to
at this point in time. So we talked
about the kind of contracts that the
generator and the evaluator would write
between themselves for this app. Um it
decided that there were 27 contract
criteria. That's a level of granularity
which we found, you know, that you
really need to make findings kind of
actionable. If you have vague criteria,
you have vague critiques. The generator
just kind of shrugs and does things.
Whereas if you have granular criteria,
um the agent knows, okay, I need to fix
this exact line.
What's kind of interesting, I thought,
you know, uh, and I want to be honest
about this part, is that out the box,
Claude is a really, really bad just
general QA agent. Um, Andrew talked
about this, uh, a little bit, uh, in his
bit, right? But the same kind of syphy
and generosity bias that everyone hits
with uh, general elements of judge
systems also applies here. Um, most of
the time in early runs it would, you
know, the QA agent would kind of find a
bug and be like, uh, fix it later, might
take two weeks. Um, uh, and then just
kind of like be done with it. Um, so we
actually had to spend an exorbitant
amount of time like going through, um,
trying to tune, you know, small layout
bugs, edge cases, and and kind of
feeding that into the prompts.
I wish there was some kind of secret to
to actually doing this, but
realistically the whole uh kind of art
to building this system and making it
good uh was kind of reading the traces.
Um the primary debugging loop was this
and not necessarily running more
experiments. It was reading what the
agent actually did um finding where its
judgment diverged from um ours as humans
and then tuning the prompt for that.
It was the same kind of muscle as
reading kind of a stack trace.
Um um one kind of tooling tip that we
had was kind of piping agent transcripts
uh into files uh kind of gpping them uh
with another agent or having another
agent kind of go through them um and
then kind of update the prompts itself
so you have some sort of like closing
the loop even on just like building uh
this harness out.
So the last thing I kind of wanted to
talk about was um how to think about
adjusting your harness as these models
kind of get better in time. I think
there's a lot of like discussion around
whether h design is kind of dead or null
especially with you know models that I
mean when I wrote this it was just open
4.6 text, but even like mythos, you
know, level level models. And
I think the key thing that we note noted
is it's really important to get a feel
for what the kind of spiky behaviors of
any individual model are and then try
and adapt your harness to kind of fill
fill the gaps. So,
um, Andrew talked about this a bit, but
you know, context resetting between
sessions, we kind of dropped that
entirely. Opus 4.5 used to have really
bad kind of context anxiety. um whereas
Opus 4.6 just you know didn't um uh as
part of a part of post training there
and so one continuous session in
compaction was was more than more than
enough to handle very long sessions.
Sprint decomposition um we don't have a
very strong opinion on this but it was
something which was really really
critical to getting Opus 4.5 to work. Um
but uh Opus 4.6 was able to kind of hold
a two-hour continuous build coherently.
uh in a way without necessarily having
to be forcefed one feature at a time. Um
the cadence at which the evaluator
should run. Previously we are running at
every single sprint per se whereas now
we were just running at at the end of a
oneshot generation from the model and
then passing back. So the harness is
still the same. We're just kind of
simplifying the specific uh kind of
loops um and kind of the recipe that
kind of goes into it. The lesson isn't
necessarily our harness was wrong, but
rather it was right for 4.5, the
frontier moved. Um, and we ran a
simplified version uh to see how it'd
work.
So, this is kind of what the final kind
of setup kind of looks like today. um
having that planner generator evaluator
loop is still the kind of core of our
system. But you can see we kind of
ditched a bunch of the other kind of um
kind of components uh that made this
slightly more compl complicated than it
had to be. Um we also as kind of
mentioned big fan of just using a file
system for shared state um uh instead of
kind of leaning on context windows uh
for very long running agents in general.
And this is an example uh of the
simplified harness running um with one
of our latest models um again very very
expensive but you can see it's actually
roughly like half the cost of the
previous runs um just because uh uh
we're kind of doing things in a slightly
more simplified manner but it's still
running over a very extended period of
time
and so this is an example of a DAW which
is basically just like a music creating
app, if you will. Um, the agent sets the
tempo, a key, it lays down the melody,
it builds the drum tracks. This is the
evaluator
um, actually going and uh, testing the
app itself. Um, we did actually listen
to like the music in this. Um, obviously
Claude can't hear at the moment and so
the music was pretty trash but the app
was really good uh in general and pretty
pretty fleshed out which you know a
model ago this is something which would
never have worked. Um, but this is
something which was possible with just a
couple rounds. Um, and this is kind of
that that meter curve which Andrea was
talking about uh kind of really in in
action.
And so I kind of wanted to close just by
saying
you don't necessarily need you know our
internal harness to to go away and start
thinking about this. We are constantly
trying to ship bits of you know these
primitives into cord code directly but
also there's nothing stopping you from
just going ahead and building something
similar to this uh kind of on your own.
So, we just shipped, you know, auto mode
is probably my favorite thing. Um, for
slightly more, you know, safe safe
yellow, if you will, um, instead of
running dangerously skip permissions all
the time. Um, we already have custom sub
agents as a primitive, right? Your
evaluator, your QA role, um, give it a
harsh system prompt and a very detailed
rubric. um Playright MTP or CL for
Chrome MTP already extremely extremely
good uh at
um web app stuff or just use computer
use if you're building kind of native
apps. Um and skills again a very nice
way to package your kind of grading
rubrics into your kind of general
development flow. Um
so yeah, five things if you're kind of
taking a photo this is the the slide I
would say to to to kind of remember. Um,
self-evaluation very much a trap. Just
use an adversarial evaluator. Um,
compaction doesn't necessarily uh does
not equal kind of coherence, right?
Lossy summaries really drift. Um,
structured handoffs uh and clean context
are a very good pattern that we've seen.
Um, don't think that sub subjective
quality isn't gradable. If you have a
strong view on what something should
look like, um, then kind of force
yourself to write it down. Um we found
this made kind of a really massive
difference uh to the quality of kind of
apps um that a model was able to
generate. And then kind of finally was
really just you know sit with the model,
read the traces. Um uh only then can you
kind of really know what bits uh of a
scaffold to delete um what bits to keep
especially as a kind of frontier uh
moves. But yeah, that's it from me. Um
thank you very much for listening. Um,
and yeah, check out our blog post. Um,
but wanted to just open up for Q&A in
general because we've been yapping for
like close to an hour now. So, um, if
you have any questions for me and
Andrew, just fire away. We'll do our
best to to try and answer them.
>> Yeah,
>> thank you. Joan from Psideide. Uh, one
question for you. when you improve the
evaluator by like reading the logs and
improving it is that uh sort of like on
a per project basis or more of a secret
source that you reuse across project
>> the goal the goal was very much to try
and do this in a way which was reusable
right like I think anyone can tune this
in a way that's that's creating you know
a very specific type of app that's fine
at that point it's not that different
from you know going ahead and just
prompting call code yourself and doing
it right I think there were just the the
key was like what are the common
patterns uh that you can kind of draw
across the model weak points right so
talking to that kind of front end design
piece we knew like what we thought good
design would be right you could give
examples like this is what you know um a
really beautiful product looks like this
is what AI slop looks like right um and
that generalizes quite well so yeah this
was all around web apps but it could
quite easily apply to to other kind of
things as
Thanks for
>> test. Yeah. Uh thank you for
presentation very interesting. Uh I was
just wondering what is your view on um
uh concept of dump zone and smart zone
of a model. So I understand like before
it was around 40%, now with 1 million
context it's about 100k is what I
understand and the way how understood
Ralph loop Ralph loop was designed is to
kind of negotiate this problem. So
basically we're keeping the model always
in a smart zone. So basically trying to
slice a task below 100 so it ex execute
the task within 100 contact zone. And
what I understand from your
presentation, you kind like advocating
not to use it anymore because we can now
rely on a compaction
and off and so on. Is it like something
you suggesting to do or we still like a
rough loop model still has its own place
given the smart and dum uh concept?
>> Yeah. Well, I suppose from Ash's
presentation um and mine, you see that
the 1 million context window is now GA
and so you have sort of a big bigger
context to use. Uh the models are more
agentic so they can sort of maintain
coherence for a longer period of time
within that context window and that
actually with the release of 4.6 we
decided to move from new context windows
to just a single long running continuous
session with compaction. So I think I
mean the whether or not you use multiple
fresh sessions or just one long running
one is probably still up to your use
case and your evals um depending on what
you you're seeing is working best but at
least for sort of this general purpose
um generator evaluator pattern with opus
4.6 we saw that it was possible to use a
single session. I don't know if you want
to add to that.
>> I I think it's also just like a
temporary problem, right? Like context
rot is, you know, a failing of like
today's models to some extent. Uh and
much less so than, you know, even just
one model generation ago. So is there a
place for for um you know, the type of
thing which you're discussing? I think
yes uh depending on use case but you
know it's not like a it's one of those
pieces which I would look at as like
okay as soon you know I'd be I'd be kind
of hunting for the model release where I
can kind of strip it out let's put it
that way.
>> I always have a lot of FOMO around
playright. I mean you said playwright
MCP is playright skills.
Do you can you speak to how to improve
the playright? Because like I imagine I
would like to like have my browser open
and then I can see the model working
through it and then maybe I can steer
it, you know, the few tabs open.
>> But like yeah, what is there some
innovation there I'm missing out on or
is is play MCP really you recommend
people use?
>> I mean play MCP or just use the CL for
Chrome MCP which is like a a slightly
more robust thing I guess around browser
control. I mean, I don't know why you
want to watch it do things. I mean, you
can, but I think that's like a trust
gap, right, today. Like, you know, the
whole point of what we're trying to get
to do here is is like you set something
off, uh, you trust it to do it do the
work and test it and you have the
confidence that it's doing it correctly
and you come back to it. Um, and that's
where, you know, yes, there's going to
be some iteration at the beginning where
you're like watching reading the traces
until you get to a point you can trust
it. But um at least internally right
like when I'm when I'm doing full stack
out dev um I have got to a point now
where I'm like okay with Opus 4.6 I can
like reliably trust the model to go
ahead read
um network errors um uh uh console
errors actually navigate up zoom in
where it needs to. um the vision is now
good enough on these models that I can
like identify overlapping text on
elements and things like that whereas
that just wasn't the case uh uh until
realistically the last you know
generation of models. So yeah I would I
would recommend um
I'm curious like with the generator
evaluator pattern What happens? Do you
can you throw unlimited tokens at it or
will it stop uh because the evaluator is
not good enough? Like can you tell me
more about that?
>> Sorry, do you mind clarifying? I kind of
messed up.
>> Yeah. So, okay, let's say um I say okay,
create like a very cool game um with
some features.
If the generator evaluator pattern that
uh creates like contracts, builds the
apps.
If I
um then it will give me back something
right. Um can I restart it again and say
like okay uh make it better I'm not
happy about it and generate the
evaluator will pick the pattern will
pick it up and make it better.
>> Yeah.
>> Or will the evaluator be not good at one
point and just say like this is it.
Um I think that's I mean one first of
all like if you want like some some
level of human in the loop in this
process that's that's like you know just
implement hooks at some point some point
in this in this loop. Um I think the bit
which was kind of surprising to us um uh
was
with this this general pattern and
especially with the kind of 4.6 six
liner models, both Sonnet and Opus, it
was extremely willing to like throw away
everything, you know, even if it had
done kind of 10 passes at something,
it was kind of very happy to just like
throw it all away and start from scratch
if for some reason it wasn't able to
like hill climb against the rubric of
the evaluator in a kind of effective
way. Um, and so
that's why kind of when we're kind of
when we were playing with this kind of
thing, we didn't naturally like lean
towards having um some kind of resume or
human in the loop uh type intervention
system I guess and we didn't really
observe we expected to but we didn't
really observe um that kind of behavior
which you're talking about where it kind
of just like evaluators like ah just
give up let's just like pass it on shall
we say. Um, yeah, it was just much more
willing to like throw away everything
and and restart and that was just a
behavior which we never saw when it was
the generator itself almost kind of
being part of its own work and being
like I'm not going to restart this whole
thing. Um, so yeah, I mean there there's
been examples which I've seen where the
evaluator is like it kind of gets fed up
and it's like right this approach you're
taking just obviously isn't working. Can
you just like delete everything and
restart? Um, which I don't know about
you guys, but vibe coding regularly I
often I often do uh uh as a human to
like you know just benefit from fresh
context windows, not have to deal with
an already messy code base etc. So it's
quite neat seeing models now also kind
of uh get to that point.
>> I'd also just briefly add obviously you
can then open that codebase in cloud
code and continue where you left off. um
sort of goes without saying and I think
we're generally thinking about what the
workflow looks like if it's sort of more
back and forth um because there's sort
of the extreme of build me a really
complex gaming application that you
don't know is it going to take three
hours is it going to take 20 hours um
it's a bit unclear so maybe there's sort
of something in the middle that's like
more of a yeah feedback loop
>> hi um I really like the idea that you
have of like you know there's a
there's a human element here where it's
like you know uh PM engineer evaluator
um PM role is a lot of the time it's
like scope creep and keeping the time
going and stuff like that but you're
just like letting this off you're
letting engineers go play in the sandbox
for ages. Um is there a harness loop
that needs to go back to the planner
eventually? Does it need to move again?
Um well maybe because we're engineers we
just decided like ah screw the we'll
just stuff it to the side. you guys.
We actually well this is where the kind
of like that kind of contracting piece
uh between the the
kind of uh evaluator and the builder
worked quite well for context in that we
typically like insert the main spec that
was generated by like the PM per se uh
into those sessions regularly so that
you know it's always a reference point
um for like okay this is what we're
still actually trying to build and the
main function of then the builder and
the generator uh sorry the builder and
the evaluator is just to like figure out
the exact feature set and tests and
contracts per se that actually satisfy
that spec. Um, but the reason we don't
is because we don't want the planner to
be like a core part of this loop. It
should be very high level. It should its
purpose really is just kind of
set out like kind of the hard outer
lines of what this product could could
be. Uh but it job is not necessarily to
come in and intervene and be like
actually this is like an impossible
feature. We should not do this and and
and edit itself. Um we kind of wanted to
keep that context relationship between
just uh just the build and the
generator. That being said like this
loop I've applied it in lots of
different ways. It doesn't have to just
be you know one generator and one
builder, right? Like that adversarial
kind of trade-off can be applied to like
a workflow consisting of multiple
separate agents, right? Um I don't know
it could uh if you're trying to do I
don't know generate evals let's say you
could use a similar harness would be
like hey generate a uh it could be like
planner generate a synthetic a generator
for synthetic data set right uh with a
QA agent then hand off to uh like an
integrator which like actually wires up
something also has a QA agent then has
like a final kind of a you can basically
add this kind of generator evaluator
thing into a multi-step workflow flow.
Uh we each like builder maybe has like a
slightly different function per se as
part of a longer workflow. So
there are different ways in which you
kind of keep things on track depending
on the task and break down uh this this
general pattern into slightly more
specified
you know uh tasks or workflows if that
makes sense.
Can you uh you mentioned that uh some of
the later tasks could not possibly be
done by an earlier model. Can you talk a
little bit about your process comparing
the tasks on the different models? Like
do you fire off the same task on Opus
4.6 Opus 4.5 Sonet or is this sort of
artistal uh co-evolving uh harness model
um setup obiating that?
>> Yeah, I mean I suppose we walk through
the history a little bit and if you look
at say the first blog post on long run
running agents versus the more recent
one um there's some pretty significant
differences there. you know, one being
what we were just discussing that the
initializer agent would build this super
comprehensive spec of say 200 different
features. Um, and then um in then the
loop would have to actually go and
execute against every single one of
those features which may lead to say
incorrect design decisions but is sort
of forced into that behavior. Whereas I
think now you're able to have sort of a
more generic creative direction set with
say Opus 4.6 basics and then just having
this this loop of the generator
evaluator. But it does yeah your model
selection does inform your harness
design very much so um of course in a
perfect world you could just sort of
throw everything at say opus 4.6 but if
you have cost concerns for example maybe
you do use opus 4.6 for planning and
then sonnet 4.6 for for the coding or
the execution that's something that we
we tend to see quite frequently. Um, but
again, if you're building specific sub
agents for each of these, you probably
want to have some evaluations to be able
to understand for that model and that
prompt how it's performing against that
task and then just optimize.
>> Do you have any advice on moving beyond
sort of these oneshot applications to
long live products where we're looking
to make changes days, weeks later? what
sort of artifacts you need to persist to
future instances to be able to know what
has come before what can I change what
should I change
>> yeah it's something which we're working
on um like right now like we use like
similar patterns for just a bunch of
random stuff internally shall we say and
so at the moment it's like set this
thing off it's running you know um on a
remote server somewhere um and I'll just
come back and check it like after this
talk let's say and then I kind of
iterate on it kind of manually uh import
code directly correctly like polish any
rough edges, that kind of thing. I think
in terms of the way that you're actually
like setting up this harness, just
having um this is why we kind of uh
default to kind of using a file system
estate uh for this kind of loop one
because it's just very easy for another
model to come up and and grip through
and and pick up what what's been going.
But one thing which I like to do is kind
of embed little bits of prompting uh
throughout this kind of loop which
basically tells it to write kind of
learnings and state to uh some kind of
uh JSON file because a model doesn't
kind of overwrite that too much. Um and
so the nice thing uh about that is
you're basically just leaving like
breadcrumbs for another model to come
and pick up. So
honestly the the key thing for me is
like how do I instruct this this harness
to leave crumbs for a human to come in
and then use cloud code on top of. So
generally it's like hey uh the shape of
that file might be like uh tried this
evaluator found this bug uh implemented
this fix this fix worked yes tick and
then continue and you have kind of like
a timestamped uh kind of time log if you
will of like everything the model has
tried the fix it's made and the final
state. Um and then also uh having some
sort of live updating kind of set of
docs if you will just very high level
here's the file structure and then those
two files to be honest are more than
enough for claw code and a human to come
in and start iterating on the app with
but that's all we're doing at the
moment. Mhm.
>> Perfect. Um, so it's very interesting to
hear the or yeah, first of all, congrats
on the presentation.
>> Um, and then I was wondering there are
kind of two approaches like you have the
agent team where multiple agents
interact with each other and then the
explicit generator critic setup.
Whatever Because in sense like the agent
team has the same setup where the main
agent instructs someone and then can act
as a critic for the sub agent. But what
are the current failure modes that
causes us to still need the specific
generator critic harness instead of just
the agent team itself? And then what's
your estimate of how many model
generations we would need to just
completely rely on the agent team.
>> Maybe I mean I can I can sort of address
the first aspect of that. So I mean one
of the limitation of firstly claude code
is is using the same harness that that
is the agent SDK. So you can technically
you should be able to build this type of
pattern into cloud code. Um, agent teams
is a useful framework for potentially
doing that because you could say have
the the generator and the evaluator sort
of intercommunicating or maybe it's the
generator as sort of the main agent and
and the evaluator is say a member of of
the agent team. Um, but I think it's
it's sort of evolved more so from that
first blog post that I shared. I think
that was like the the result of that to
some extent to try and make that more
generally available. Um, but one of the
things you're limited by obviously is
like clawed code would just have to run
on your machine. I think with the agent
SDK, you can also just run it in more of
a cloud environment and a sandboxed
environment for long periods of time and
um without it it failing um or you
having to run like caffeinate on your
machine. Um, but I think yeah, cloud
code is a good testing ground for
building out any of these types of
harnesses to experiment and explore and
see what works before maybe you build it
into the agent SDK and then actually
deploy it as its own application. Um,
and yeah, I mean again I would just
experiment, see if agent teams is
something that makes sense for you or if
maybe just using regular sub aents or
some other framing of it, it works
better. But yeah, people are using agent
teams like a ton. I I don't know if you
>> Yeah. Well, well, this is the thing is I
don't think we have like a super
strongly opinioned viewpoint on like um
what is the best at any you know set up
at any given moment in time. It's why
Boris always like updates his tweets
like this is what I'm doing now. Um like
agent teams was something which a bunch
of people loved internally um and so we
were like okay let's ship it let's see
what people think about it in the field.
Um I'm not saying we will but it you
know we regularly on ship things as
well. Um and I do see the generator
evaluator
kind of pattern as like a subset of that
like team's approach to thinking about
sub agent design. Um not necessarily
like contradictory to it per se. You
know you can imagine like you know
classic way in which teams breaks down
is like you know front end back end um
some sort of integrator between them
like sub agents. Each of those probably
deserve their own kind of critic um uh
kind of agent pairing with them for
example. Um, so you can kind of see how
the two concepts like overlap. Um, just
the general idea behind this is, you
know, most people when they're running
cloud code at the moment their goal
isn't to like oneshot an app over like
six hours and so that isn't necessary to
primitive which we like by default like
ship uh there. Um so yeah
>> one thing I was wondering have you also
tried like a critic that gets the
context of the generator then you I feel
like if it has some clue about the
traces of the agent or like the
executor.
>> Yeah.
>> Is that currently the case and the the
critic?
>> Uh we we use like a handoff pan. I I
would be very hesitant of that. We did
try this, but this is the whole like
muddying of of like thoughts between the
two two model streams. I think it's
actually much more effective to just let
it judge the output um and just provide
instead of being like, hey, you made a
misstep when building this by doing X
and that's what's resulting in this
issue. It's much more effective to just
have the value to be like this is an
issue and then let the generator purely
reflect on its own work and then try and
figure out how to fix that issue. Um
otherwise, you kind of just see We found
that it's very easy for the model to
like kill itself that something is
working or not and that feed into the
evaluator as well.
>> Last note on that. I think it would then
be interesting if you for the training
team if you could train like the the
generator to predict what a critic
currently said.
>> Yeah.
>> To to have it be more honest about what
it did and stuff.
>> Maybe we'll welcome that.
Um I want to ask more about traceability
like I use u superpowers or like my own
prompts to generate like multiple
subentions to implement my let's say my
software or app but what happens is like
I don't really know I want to go back
and see where it actually went wrong
even but then I'm not able to figure out
how to find those traces. How what do
you use for traceability is my question.
When you have so many like five six
agents running in background like um
yeah
>> um
to be honest a lot of it is just reading
through traces by hand. Um
we do a lot of that I would say
anthropic in general just like reading
through traces by hand. Um, we also just
like have, you know, hacked together
various things where we, you know, point
Claude at uh a bunch of traces um uh
with some custom prompts uh to try and
identify like issues with the loop like
this is where it veered off and whatnot.
Um we kind of use that as like a first
pass I would say maybe to just kind of
like see where something where where
like where something might have gone
wrong. But to be honest, by far in a way
the the the best approach at least that
we use internally is just just reading
reading the traces by hand. Um only then
do you kind of like truly get to kind of
relate to what the model is trying to
actually do. Um yeah,
thanks for the talk. Um I have a few
questions. Uh first of all, how do you
measure the quality of a harness agent
pair? is it it feels like a vibe check
like it's a green field. Uh let's build
an app.
>> Um but let's say you're you're going
into a new project maybe brownfield. Um
it feels like a vibe check or some kind
of art. Can you make it more scientific
or is that just not feasible?
>> I mean the way that we've thought about
it at least, right, is like we specify
the rubrics in kind of extreme detail at
the kind of generator and and evaluator
level, right? So we talked about for
example those four kind of criteria
that's very high level the rubric which
we use for like design taste let's say
and so we set those up for various bits
of this app right so that can be just
for the design element maybe another
piece for like how we think about um
kind of API design let's say um um
code quality whatever and we kind of use
those as the
uh kind of various set of rubrics which
are hill climbing against right and and
the evaluator's jobs that you know
encourage the builder to hill climb
against those. And so for any given app
or output, we have like a signal of this
is where the model started on those
those kind of criteria and this is where
we've kind of ended at. Now that's less
useful for like kind of like you said
working on um kind of newer code bases,
but it still applies, right? Like you
could point you just have to start the
loop in a different way. um you would
just point the evaluator at a given
codebase um and be like this is where we
are now and then uh uh give it the the
spec of what you're trying to achieve
and then let the loop kind of iterate
against those kind of criteria. So like
a necessarily a one set of eval. It's
kind of like here are the criteria for
what we think good looks like. Then
letting the uh evaluator and the
generator come up with a set of kind of
tests uh or contracts that need to
satisfy and then letting it just as a
harness hill climb against those. Um
that's not super comparable across
different products and runs. Um but it's
it's very useful for for yeah within a
product or run. Also this um this
particular pattern is great for green
field like you said but it's quite
opinionated. You know it might be using
react like postgress as a database and
node on the back end but your brownfield
app might be using something totally
different or the rubric that we've
created for what we think you know good
sort of design patterns are would might
be totally different in your project. So
I think that's why we're proposing this
as more of a pattern that you would then
um tailor towards you know your
application.
One follow question
work.
>> Yeah.
>> Um do you use uh do you like direct the
harness individually and how do you
cooperate as a team on that? I find it's
very hard to like uh when I share my
screen and I'm working conversationally,
it's very hard for people to keep up and
the other way around I find it
cumbersome to dictate what to prompt. Uh
how do you cooperate as a team? Do you
have like team owned harnesses?
Um,
>> is it maybe a good feature for cloth
code?
>> Um,
yeah, maybe maybe I I think we we
probably do have work to do on that,
right? Like I think like um
quite often what happens internally is
like you know people come up with these
ideas and then they're generally quite
bottoms up adopted by different teams
and um it's then the job of the kind of
original you know uh idea holders should
we say which was Priy in this case to
kind of maintain it and make it kind of
composable and generalizable for
different teams and different teams will
adapt it and and you know uh make it
useful for like their section of the
codebase let's say um but we don't have
any
good things in that sense. I think like
you know even just observability like
some of the people talked about right is
like a um generally speaking a thing
which is not fully solved yet for these
like ultra longunning uh agents and yeah
interesting area of kind of green field
software to explore.
>> Yeah that is that is an interesting one
whether it should be sort of a
collaborative experience in in cloud
code or even cloud.ai AI I think in just
leveraging software engineering best
practices with version control and make
your commits and pull requests or if
you're working on your own using
something like git work trees so that
you're not overwriting the the file
system on multiple different features
all makes sense but yeah I think when it
comes to collaboration maybe it's
something that you know doesn't happen
quite as much because people just build
these projects as Ash said from the
ground up and then sort of you know
present them to the rest of the
Um, hi uh Jose from Mercedes-Benz
research and development here. Hi,
thanks for the talk. Um, while looking
at it, I thought okay, it looks a lot
like a scrum team, a feature team
working for longer times uh on a a
product and I was thinking um how does
human in the loop look like in that
scenario? Um because you have you had
this kind of sprints. Uh have you
thought about a sprint review kind of
moment where where you as a human get
asked, oh hey, here's what we built the
last two hours.
>> Yeah.
>> What's it looking like for you?
>> Yeah. Should we subject our agent to the
same trauma that like engineers go
through um of of scrum review? Uh
I mean like the whole point of this
general the general idea which behind
this talk and also what we're trying to
do is like trying to be as like AGI pled
as possible right like how do we build
harnesses where we don't need a human in
the loop right like what does that look
like are we using this today for
everything obviously not right um uh but
the goal is you know this is this is a
technique or a pattern which should
extend very nicely such that you don't
have a human a loop for most things if
you did right it's like uh you know
hooks is probably the main primitive
to just basically inject uh given some
sort of specific type of stop condition
let's say with an evaluator um to
basically like hand back to human allow
some kind of developer message input and
then continue the loop uh would be like
kind of the simple way to implement it
but yeah to be honest we're kind of
exploring this from a
what can we do fully autonomously kind
of approach as opposed to thinking this
as like here's called code and and like
how do we make this like you know more
powerful per se. It's very much like a
kind of more green field exploration of
agent design.
>> Yeah. No, of course it's just like um if
if if I would get the chance to review
it maybe a few hours in and I might be
able to steer it in a bit way better
way.
>> Yeah.
>> So that eight hours later it's more like
the one kind of project I would like to
have.
>> Yeah. I mean I get what you're saying. I
think the question then is is like
should that be like a permanent feature
of the harness or is that just like a
a thing which you should have like kind
of basically prompted around when
building the harness, right? So we would
have that, right? We would run this this
this harness on loop um and we would
have you know we might spin up like 10
generations of different things and like
three of them succeed and seven of them
fail in like random ways. And then we
would just sit down with those seven,
read through them, uh adjust the
prompting of the main harness and then
and then try again. and until we get to
a point where we're like quite happy
leaving it run uh leaving it to run
fully autonomously. So ultimately that's
still the end goal for us as opposed to
being like
basically giving up on the harness and
being like okay we'll just insert a
human here to to like cover for any kind
of stability issues. Instead we'd rather
embed that and bake that into the
harness itself um in the first place.
Have you used this to build anything
like sort of like non-green field or I
guess like production like anything in
cloud code itself or like have you used
it for actual features and and seeing it
to the end?
>> Um I think I mean this does mostly
extend to green field projects. I think
for brownfield maybe you do need a
little bit more control um as you're
starting to build out your own rubrics
and and patterns. Um I mean what we're
seeing in brownfield is that if you look
at the whole software development life
life cycle it's not just the coding
aspects that people are starting to use
something like cloud code for it might
be say there's like autonomous
monitoring happen happening um and then
that could feed into say generating some
kind of like issue or or feature request
that could then just feed into um an
agent that would then go through to make
the pull request and then there's sort
of the pull review um already happening
and then maybe you're just reviewing
that before you actually merge. So I
think there there are other ways to
automate the whole software development
life cycle um uh in a brownfield
project. But I think this particular
pattern maybe without a lot of testing
within your project and building like
customizing it for your project. It's
probably more suited towards brand new
applications.
Have you built any green field apps that
like I don't know like an internal
tooling or or anything like that that
you've been using like not just a demo
sort of like
>> Yeah. Um to be frank, I can't really
like talk to like Intel tooling too
much, but a good anecdote of this was um
like a lot of the the new and fun stuff
that you see in C code will will like um
uh when I'm speaking to the team and
working with them on stuff
use a lot of the lessons from this per
se, like in in like even just general
hands-on
uh cold code usage, the way that they
prompt, you know, the main uh model to
to spin up a sub agent let's say and and
and go after something or as kind of
Andrew said right in kind of monitoring
and bug fixing loops like you know when
generating a fix like should you have a
separate evaluator and a generator go
after the same thing so a lot of these
principles apply um is it like you know
one for one this maybe not but it's like
taking the good bits of this or whatever
you think is is kind of applicable to a
certain space and field and then kind of
running with it in your own way
Hey, when you say reading the traces, is
that literally just like the raw output
or is there something more specific
you've prompted it to like write this to
file, these are the sorts of things I
care about and I want to see?
>> No, you got to read the whole thing.
Read the whole thing. I do think it's
like a really important skill when
building agents in general is to like
empathize as much with the model. Um
this was like there's an interesting uh
anecdote which we used when we were
building for example the agent harness
for called for chrome um which is our
kind of browser use thing. Um,
and we would run this like experiment
where like imagine if you know you were
trying to navigate a web page and click
around where like you know you
effectively doing with your eyes closed
and like every 10 seconds you just
opened it to see like a static page and
then closed it again and then had to
like do things. Um, and like really
putting yourself in the shoes of the
model um is kind of like this kind of
empathetic skill set which you need to
develop. Um, and the only way to really
do that is to like spend as much time
with these models, but also, yeah,
reading through line by line being like,
"Oh, why did it think this? Oh, I can
kind of see why I did that." And then
kind of adjusting the way you instruct
it next time to to do better. Um, but
that's why I think call for Chrome is
very good was just really just like
spending a lot of time as a team uh
closing our eyes and trying to navigate
web pages for example. So, um, yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And I think then actually
taking those learnings and putting them
into say your prom templates or your
cloud MD or building a skill or just
generally understanding how to sort of
avoid that type of behavior in the
future. I know cloud code now has auto
memory for sessions as well. So it's
sort of constantly memorizing little
things as it goes. Um but yeah, you can
learn quite quickly from reading some
traces like where things might be going
wrong.
>> Cool. Should we wrap up there? Um, I
think we have a few minutes left, but
we'll be around in general in case you
guys want to ask any questions or just
chat. But otherwise, thanks for coming
down. Last question of the day.